welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy that couldn't think of a witty
intro so we're just skipping over it
and getting right into our breakdown of
invincible the first three episodes have
just dropped on amazon prime video and
throughout this we're gonna be breaking
down all this story
easter eggs and the way the book handles
things differently
robert kirkman recently stopped into
kevin smith's podcast fat man beyond to
promote the show
and he said that because he wrote the
original when he was about 23
he'd come up with a lot of new ways to
handle a storyline
and those changes are clear right from
the off i recently been a bit of an
omni man myself and gone through the
omnibus
thank you and i was surprised to see how
differently things were handled
what you mean that was a crap joke
anyway one of my biggest criticisms
about the work
is that things come very easy for
invincible early on
though this sets up the big plot
developments that i won't spoil here
the first three episodes definitely put
way more roadblocks in mark grayson's
way
and it also introduces several
characters far earlier than they appear
in the source material
now we open on two security guards at
the white house discussing superhuman of
asian training
before the conversation moves to one of
their stepsons
this guy talks about going to london
with his boy matt and the introduction
of episodes one and two mirror each
other quite a lot
similar to what we see here we get two
people talking about family in front of
a famous building
that switches from the white house to
buckingham palace we learn that matt has
had a rough time
and it's clear that his stepdad cares
about him greatly even though they
disagree on certain things
this father and son relationship is very
much going to be mirrored in nolan and
mark
who two will have to tackle their
differences the further we get into the
story
unfortunately this touching intro is
broke up by the arrival of the mauler
twins
or other clones though they look like
your typical super thugs
the pair have a genius level iq between
them and this has allowed them to master
several things
such as cloning now throughout the work
the pair constantly argue over who the
original one really is
and every time they pop up it gets more
entertaining
come the end of episode 3 there's
actually a big change up where one of
the twins uses the other as a shield
which leads to his death this isn't
really reflected in the book
so it's going to be interesting to see
whether that one returns or not
now here to say the day are the
guardians of the globe a justice league
parody whose name plays on the guardians
of the galaxy
in the source material they don't
actually appear until issue 7
and they're introduced in the scene in
which we see them being called together
by omniman
amongst their members are darkwing a
batman parody
red rush who is the flash war woman and
martian man
as well as the funniest aquaman parody
i've ever seen
i actually love getting to see these in
action as
in the comics they're taking out almost
immediately after we meet them
here we see them with their powers fully
on show and the animation is also
handled by the same team that do a lot
of dc's animated movies
it perfectly sets up that these are the
heroes on earth
and also leads into why omniman does
what he does
now their backs are against the ropes
until he shows up
and it seems like he's earth's perfect
protector one thing i always wondered
with the character
is whether he was purposely supposed to
resemble j jonah jameson
or if that was just a complete
coincidence my itch over this has not
been scratched
and has been made even worse by the fact
that he's now voiced by jk simmons who
of course played him in the spider-man
movies
if only there was some way i could
quickly find out whether that's the
truth or not now
as for omniman in the first couple of
issues of the comics
he informs us that he's from a planet
known as filtron
which possesses a highly advanced
civilization the people of the planet
are very much
gods and throughout the universe they've
sent their scouts
to apparently be the protectors of peace
and justice throughout the work we learn
a lot more about veltrum and their
overall plans in the galaxy
that i think a lot of people who don't
know the surprises are absolutely gonna
love
the older veltromites are the slower
they age and on earth omniman adopted
the name nolan and became a best-selling
author
with his wife debbie voiced by sandra oh
they raised their son mark who is voiced
by stephen yen
the family known as the graysons are of
course named after batman's sidekick
dick
and mark himself even looks like him in
several ways
now we are introduced to mark reading a
comic called saying stock
who we learn as a master of the
metaphysical arts
when we see it in a poster it does look
like it's wearing a doctor strange
costume
so in my opinion it's definitely tied
into that i'm guessing he's sort of
playing on crypto and ghost dog too
and hey whatever happens here get us
more saiyan's dog
now mark spent most of his life waiting
for his powers to manifest
and he's lived a pretty normal one aside
from having a superpowered father
in school mark wants to stand up and do
the right thing
and at one point he attempts to get a
bully named todd to stop harassing a
girl named amber
this goes badly and he gets the crap
kicked out of him
now i was talking about how easy he has
it in the source material
is because when mark first fights todd
he already has his powers so it's very
one-sided
the same thing happens at bergamot and
mark quits his job
no questions asked which doesn't even
annoy his father
i'm glad they took the time out properly
to put obstacles in his way
so it's not just an easy ride as when i
was reading it i did think here that
this guy's just got no challenges in his
life
now similar to the book mark discovers
he has powers when taking out the trash
at bergamot
and he learns to fly with his dad
initially in the workers powers were
thought to be solar-based similar to
superman's
however he can operate fine without
being powered up by the sun
making him far superior upon returning
home
nolan states that he wishes mark hadn't
got his abilities at all
as this does complicate things quite a
lot clearly he now has more of an
attachment
and knows the perils his son will face
but if you've read the book then you'll
also understand
why this talk has a lot of subtext to it
i'll stop glossing over stuff like that
though and just focus more on the
initial episodes that we get
but yeah definitely read the comics
because you're gonna absolutely love
them
now another interesting change up is
that his school life is very much kept
separate from the power side of things
as in the original work there was
actually a plot involving a teacher that
was kidnapping students
and strapping explosives to them todd
tries to beat up mark
and when he fails the latter realizes
that he needs something to punch
donning a homemade costume he travels
out to stop some bank robbers that are
in league with a super villain called
titan who's voiced by mahashala ali
titan is basically johnny storm with
rock powers instead of fire
and he even encases his body in stone by
saying rock on
this entire scene is taken directly from
the comics and it's an awesome first
fight for the character against someone
that will be popping up later down the
line
shortly after his father takes him to a
superhero tailor
named r rosenborn who's voiced by mark
hamill
he wants to hook him up with an iconic
costume but first he needs a name from
mark
now i absolutely love how throughout the
show the first time that invincible is
said in an episode
it leads into the title screen which
slowly starts to get bloodier and
bloodier
hopefully the gorier the show gets the
more this does too
as it's an awesome way to keep us
engaged with the name of the series
at home mark's mother debbie says that
it feels like she's been left behind
because he's starting to become more
like his father a big thing that mark
will likely wrestle with throughout the
series is which parent he is most like
and in the book we do see variations on
the character in other timelines
who have taken on different paths with
his father the pair play catch around
the world
and this moment is pretty much lifted
directly from the source material
although it shows that the pair do have
similarities with humans
but in terms of scope they're far above
what mortal men are capable of
it's at this point that mark gains the
name invincible and whether this is true
or not is something that's constantly
put to the test with the character
mark has his first flight in his new
costume and this involves him going
stratospheric
he actually goes outside of the earth to
return to the planet before gliding
through the vast skyscrapers of his home
and it's a brilliant scene to watch this
joy is quickly cut short though
when a supervillain attacks and mark
takes down his first bad guy in his new
persona
cut to what i'm calling the credit scene
and we see a part that is lifted
directly from the source material
as mentioned earlier this is how the
guardians of the globe are introduced in
the comics
and we see them being called together
before they're brutally murdered by
omniman
i absolutely love how red rush talks
about how because he's so fast
even small conversations feel like agony
and it's difficult to keep his attention
this is something that barry allen is
also wrestled with and across the globe
we see immortal taking on a villain who
is similar to the vulture from
spider-man
in the comics we learn that this bad guy
actually has cancer
much like the vulture did but immortal
doesn't web him up
and instead just tosses him into space
aquaris is in his home of atlantis
which also seems to be based on the
gungan city in the phantom menace
and it looks like he just sits about
waiting for stuff to happen
jump to war woman and we see her as a
ceo of a company
which is something that dc have done
with diana prince from time to time
in the comics this scene showed her with
a girlfriend and the pair were attacked
by the god of war
who was obviously playing on ares the
team unite at their base
and we realize that they've been
summoned by omniman who shows up and
absolutely annihilates them this
over-the-top gory scene is amazing
and he managed to recapture the feel of
the comics perfectly
whilst also taking things almost above
that with just how brutal nolan becomes
i loved watching red rush punching him
as his head was crushed
and let us know instantly that this
wasn't your typical superhero cartoon
now a big difference to the book is that
omniman remains with the bodies of the
guardians
whereas in the source material he flees
this makes the government
not really have a place to start when
investigating the character
but here it's clear straight away that
they know something could be off with
him
the immortal is beheaded but as i'm sure
you can guess from his name he can be
resurrected
and this is why we see his body being
sealed and taken off in episode 2.
here we see the other side of matt and
his stepdad's trip
as the pair visit london and also
discuss tyranny and the queen
matt states that though the old lady
looks sweet she actually comes from a
long line of tyrants
and this is of course reflected in
omniman who seems like a good guy
but clearly has a darker side to him the
bergamot trash bag mark toss 2 shows up
at this point
and it segues beautifully into the
cleanup of the guardians of the globe
now it's at this point that we're
introduced to cecile steadman who shows
up
way earlier in the story than he did in
the comics stedman voiced by walton
goggins
is the head of the guardians and he's
such a high-ranking member of society
that the cia
don't even know he exists he has a
teleportation device that apparently
costs the taxpayer millions of dollars
every time he uses it
and he becomes very much the person that
sets the missions for mock
deb is worried that nolan hasn't come
home and this is sort of reordered from
the comics
as he actually got trapped in the
dimension that he does at the end of the
episode
which caused a lot of her anxiety here
though it's because he's recovering from
the attack on the guardians
but i do appreciate how they change
things up with omniman and the guardians
looking a little worse for wear
mark goes and takes on the flaxsens and
we learn that when they're in our world
they age rapidly this makes them call
off the invasion
but they do return throughout the
episode to try and invade the planet
now through this action scene we're
introduced to the teen team a play on
teen titans
headed up by rexplode their members
include duplicate
robot and adam eve who becomes a big
character in the series
eve is one of the most powerful heroes
in the image comics universe
and she has the ability to rearrange
mata at a molecular level
however because she's just a pretty girl
that occasionally shoots pink lights out
of her hands
that's all she's ever really seen as
even though she doesn't wear a mask
she's not recognized in high school and
the series very much follows her
as she gains her independence dating
rexplo the character is cheated on and
put through the ringer
but to me she's absolutely the best
character in this series
now a love triangle sort of develops
between her and mark and amber
which too reflects the journey with his
parents he has someone that he could
live a superpowered lifestyle with
or a more grounded person that will
bring better focus to his humanity
mark's personal life definitely takes a
bigger focus in episode 2
but we also see more action when another
invasion happens
in the comics we discovered that in the
flaxsense dimension
the time between invasions was 30 years
for them
so they could work out the kinks in
their rapid aging on earth
they now have bracelets which counter
the effects but invincible in a teen
team
managed to take them out nolan comes out
of his coma
and above the house he and mark practice
fighting
cecile comes in and informs them that a
threat to earth has returned
and over the decades an attacker known
as alan the alien
has arrived to take on the planet's best
champion this is to test earth's
defenses
and typically omniman has handled this
however
mark has been given the job this time
and he actually talks it out with him
we discover that alan was assigned to
urath and not earth
and he goes back to his people
completely embarrassed he does return
later in the comics to fill in one of
the bigger mysteries so keep an eye out
for the guy
and also shout out seth rogen for doing
the voice
the invaders return once more but this
time they're beaten by omniman
who travels into the dimension with them
to destroy them from the inside
debbie is no longer worried about him
being missing and she has accepted that
he's gonna be okay
in the flax inside mention omniman says
you don't understand
earth isn't yours to conquer and if you
know how things go then you'll
understand why this line has such
importance
nolan spends three months there wrecking
shop and the flaxsens open a portal for
him
to return home in back on earth it
becomes public knowledge that the
guardians of the globe are dead
and we jump to episode 3 and see a
ceremony for the group
i was kind of got that savage dragon
from the image comics didn't show up
here
as he did in the source material but i
guess they're just trying to keep the
universe streamlined
this event develops into their funeral
and we see as nolan gives a touching
eulogy on them that describes their
lives which are heavily linked in with
their dc comic counterparts
this includes martian man who was ousted
by his own people
and war woman who came from another time
now it's at this time that the demon
investigator damien dark blood
starts to narrow in on omniman the
government put a surveillance team on
the house
and this wasn't the case in the source
material as omniman didn't remain at the
scene of the crime
so he was never a suspect robot voiced
by zachary quinto
is signed up to create the new guardians
of the globe and we'll discuss later on
what his overall plan could be
mark reaches out to amber but he quickly
sees firsthand how difficult it will be
to balance a relationship
and be a hero in the comics he and amber
have a very strained relationship
because he has to keep nipping off
whenever there's a problem and this adds
a lot of dynamics to the triangle
between her
him and adam eve now speaking of eve she
catches rexplo
cheating with duplicate i don't know if
it's this counts as a foursome or if
it's just to want some
because you can copy yourself or is that
a twosome i don't know either way
i do feel like this references the scene
in watchmen in which silk specter
catches dr manhattan duplicating himself
whilst the pair get it on that might be
a reach though
or rather a reach around elsewhere
auditions are held for the guardians of
the globe in an arena
that seems similar to the danger room
from x-men this recruiting new member
storyline is a staple in comics
and my favorite take on it is in jla by
grant morrison
which led to green arrow being recruited
to the justice league
several of the applicants here stand out
including a gorilla man which is riffing
on gorilla grodd from the flash and also
a woman known as shrinking ray who can
change his size
some of the atom and ant-man the new
team also includes black samson
and monster girl who is a 28 year old
that's been cursed with her body clock
going backwards
which means she constantly gets younger
she can also transform into a giant
green monster similar to the hulk
and she kicks the crap out of her
explode now she has a lot of
similarities with robot
even if she doesn't think so similar to
her he's judged a lot on his appearance
but we see throughout the comics that he
has humanity within him
which we'll no doubt be covering in
future episodes amber shows up to marx
but he's called out to fight someone
attacking mount rushmore
ripped directly from the comics this
villain says bow down before dark
seismic
which is a play on bow down before dark
side
atom even invincible team up to take him
on and we discover that he has bracelets
which shoots seismic waves
similar to shocker from spider-man upon
returning home omniman congratulates
mark for giving up on a girl to continue
his duty
and it very much speaks to how he's
willing to put his mission above his
wants and needs
in respect once you know his full arc
these conversations work really well
i'd be interested to hear what people
think of these moments in the comments
below
eve takes down the photos of her and rex
and quits the team
before traveling to marx to see him
kissing amber at this point she is very
much
carving out her own niche and making it
on her own we then travel to
a super villain prison similar to the
raft or bel reeve and also see a god who
reminded me a lot of steve rogers
in the cells are several characters
playing on villains like the lizard
killer croc
multiple man and wendigo we see that the
muller twins are prisoners here
but robot then frees them one of the
twins uses the other as a shield to
escape
but i do feel like there will be more
cloning going on as
in the comics they're pretty much always
a double act now we will be discussing
why robot probably did this and some of
the big reveals from the comics
so if you don't want it ruined then i
recommend that you turn off now also
thanks for sticking with me this far
into the video and make sure you drop a
thumbs up if you've enjoyed the
breakdown
anyway robot freed the characters
because due to their scientific minds
they're the only ones who can bring the
immortal back to life
in the comics they regenerate his body
and he seeks out revenge for omniman
killing him
now why omniman did this is also another
thing i think many of you will have
questions over
so i thought we discuss it here in the
spoiler section of the show
just in case you can't wait but if you
can wait get the hell out of here turn
the video off
now basically beltrum isn't this
peaceful planet that we're
led to believe and the people of it are
actually conquerors that travel through
space
enslaving planets because earth has
defenses like the guardians of the globe
it's almost impossible for a
superpowered being to swoop in
and just take things over thus omniman
has been used as a sort of trojan horse
the voltromites typically send a
superpowered being to the planet
and they then have their masquerade as a
hero this allows them to carry out
guerrilla attacks to weaken the planet's
defenses
and this is why omniman destroyed all of
the guardians
i'm guessing the same thing will be
happening in the show however
judging off the way that everything's
sort of been changed they could go in a
different direction
either way what a great collection of
episodes and obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on them in the comments
below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
show on the 31st of march
in which we're giving away three copies
of a marvel 4k boxer of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episodes
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
you want somebody else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
falcon in the winter soldier which will
be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire episode from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace